i think the fact that you did win an
oscar marley really did pave the way
one of the things that i have such a
deep respect for
is how the film
treats
the
viewer as if they are just watching a
family
exactly
there there are so many levels in this
film it's not just
for deaf people or it's not about just
deaf people it's for everyone
and it does include deaf people it does
include deaf culture it includes sign
language but people who just happen to
be deaf it's part of the story that
we're human beings just like anybody
else we're working class people we earn
a living we're trying to be parents
we're trying you know we have kids
there's so many things that happen in
this film that you'll recognize that you
can identify with there's singing
there's deaf culture there's fishing
there's parenting it's all in one
package in this film and it's such a
good
film that people really love watching it
from what i've seen you know again going
back to hollywood
we're grateful for
van dome and pathe who
put trust in our direction and put it in
sean heater's hands as the director and
writer to use authentic deaf actors to
tell this story
and for apple tb plus to pick it up
right after sundance winning four awards
which is unprecedented
for people to see and believe in us
really feels validating that it was a
movie that everybody should see
it was and all the love that we got it
was a giant success at sundance it was
bought for 25 million dollars an
unprecedented amount
there you go it's funny
thank you
[Applause]
i was looking at sundance to see if
anyone beat our record not yet you know
i don't mean to brag but i feel good
i've been waiting for someone to beat us
bud
well and just like marley mentioned so
our producers from path and vendome i
feel like
that group of folks planted a seed and
that seed blossomed
from this french film
which
started to bloom and become stronger and
stronger into a beautiful apple tree a
tree fell down apple fell off that tree
and ran down the hill like a snowball
effect just plowing into hollywood with
deaf talent
and
and for
them for the producers to hire us three
actors who are deaf authentic deaf to
carry a film it's unprecedented as i
said it's never been done before it is
so rare and your children are codas
four and your daughter i have a daughter
yes who is a coda right now we have two
interpreters here who actually codas
themselves believe it or not
and so
that's my daughter zakota her daughter
is a coda
and so
thank you for sharing this conversation
and bridging two worlds between the
hearing and deaf world it's so important
and for so many codas who are younger
who have hearing friends
they really struggle to understand them
and that's why increasing this awareness
with young people they can become more
accepting
[Music]